hello everyone thank you for joining us
at microsoft research summit 2021 my
name is
assistant professor from mit
so today my presentation's title is
computationally efficient large scale ai
so nowadays we are solving more
complicated ai problems with larger data
sets which require more computation
however the morris law is slowing down
and the amount of computation per unit
cost is no longer increasing at historic
rate
therefore we need computationally
efficient ai
according to this study training a
single ai model can emit as much carbon
as five cars in their lifetimes
so this is mentioning the evolved
transformer with neural architecture
search
doing such neural architecture search
for transformers is taking
250 gpu years which emit a carbon
emission of
626 000 pounds which is equal to 5 cars
in their lifetime
while in this presentation we'll
describe techniques to reduce this
training cost by
all four orders of magnitude
and that is achieved by using this once
for our network with with sharing and
decoupling training and search
conventional neural architecture
research method is computationally
expensive because
because and outside this very already
expensive training forward and backward
loop there is a meta controller for many
different search episodes and four
different for many different hardware
devices we have to repeat
this expensive search loop
we propose ones for our model that
decouple training and search
so we train only once and get these ones
for our model this is taking roughly
three times the computation right
running a single ai model when training
a single ai model
but this can be amortized by across many
different devices and across different
search episodes so during search time we
just need to sample from the lines for
our model which is very light weighted
and we can train only once and get many
different sub-networks for free to fit
diverse hardware constraints like we can
deploy a larger model for for iphone 12
and we can deploy a smaller model for
iphone xs
the users may have both the high-end
phones and also low info
we want to be inclusive for users who
have those low info
but it is very expensive to design those
neural neural network models of
different sizes at large scale
so one small model is like a large scale
producer that can produce neural
networks of different sizes at very low
search and training cost
similarly we can deploy a larger
sub-network for the dpu and smaller one
for iot device
and turns out this method performs even
better than training the same
architecture from scratch due to better
supervision and regularization
and similarly we can deploy a larger
sub-network for full battery case and a
smaller sub-network for the battery
saving mode
and it turns out we can train 10 to the
19th different sub-networks at the same
time
which is very competitionally efficient
since we are paying over only the three
times the overhead compared with
training one model but we can obtain 10
to the 19 models at the same time
and this is an energy to the human brain
which activates sparsely
and the white s4 model contains many
child networks that are also sparsely
activated not all of them are working at
the same time
and these child networks share the
weights with y4 network and they are
trained jointly
in this method we can reduce the carbon
footprint of ai by using such a more
advanced technique to do neural
architecture search
so having obtained this wi-fi model we
can perform evolutionary architecture
search by using a latency and accuracy
predictor and if the model meets the
target latency then we keep the
architecture otherwise we resample the
architecture by mutation and crossover
this once for our model is very
effective it can reduce the latency by
2.6 times
faster while achieving a top-line
emission accuracy of more than 80
percent
and the accuracy is 3.8 percent higher
compared with the efficient net
the other result is measured on the
google pixel 1 and cpu and the y-axis is
the image net accuracy
so not only on this general-purpose
hardware but also on specialized
hardware like the settings rpp we can
achieve a better throughput so compared
with mobile v2 in grey i'm not that in
yellow and our one small model in green
we can improve the throughput by almost
50 percent
so measured on designing co-9eg fpga
we can improve the throughput from
roughly 100 g per second to 155 gb per
second
on the right hand side is a smaller fpga
again using the same ones for our model
but just
using a smaller subnet it can achieve a
higher throughput of 76 compared with 48
and 44
which indicates a brand new
methodology for improving the fpga's
performance by just smartly designing
the neural network model without the
need to change the rtl
so our model has a higher arithmetic
intensity
which is less memory bounded therefore
the fpga can fully utilize its dsps
so this this figure compares the modern
deep neural nets with respect to the
amount of computation which is on the
x-axis
show in max the amount of multi
multiplication and accumulates the
y-axis is the amount of
accuracy
so the smaller the computation the
higher the accuracy the better the
quality so here the one small model can
achieve
80 80 percent top on accuracy but
require only 595
million max
and it says a world record in the open
division of the imo perth inference
benchmark which is the olympic game for
ai chip and ai influence throughput
it can achieve more than 1 million
images per second or 8100 gpus
and
three and reaches the accuracy
of
of resonance 50 level image length
accuracy
so we can see that these auto mr design
models consistently outperform those
human baselines
and it provides a turnkey solution for
hardware and the neural architecture
code design
so this was for our approach
i received many awards in the third
fourth and fifth low power computer
vision challenge in multiple hardware
platforms cpu
dsp fpd and for multiple tasks like
detection segmentation
and also a detection segmentation
classification visual records and also
and also in language modeling
this method is widely adopted in
industry both on the cloud and also on
the edge
okay so apart from those
2d images let's also talk about the more
computationally challenging part which
is
3d
videos so we'll introduce tsm temporal
shift module for efficient and scalable
video understanding on edge devices
the video is the biggest biggest big
data
and the amount of videos are growing
explosively they are 10 to the fifth
hours of videos uploaded to youtube
every day
and efficient video processing is
essential for both the cloud and also on
the edge
however those video understanding is
very computationally expensive
people need to model those temporal
relationship as well as the spatial
spatial modeling
for example by just looking at a single
image
we can now tell whether we are putting
something from left to right or putting
something from right to left
therefore we need a temporal modeling
people used to use
a 3d convolution or lstm or or its
derivatives
to perform those temporal modeling which
is very computationally
inefficient
we propose a new approach
which is temporal shift to perform
temporal modeling
so tsm stands for temporal shift module
which shifts part of the channels along
the temporal dimension to facilitate the
information exchange among neighboring
frames
and for online video understanding
scenario we only shift part of the
channels from the past to the future
and the nature of the shift is that it
doesn't contain any actual flops just by
moving the pointer and it also contains
zero parameters so it's very convenient
and efficient
to add tsm to the 2d backbone
so here we can see
tsm is very low cost up to 2-6 times
reduction of computation compared with
prior art while achieving much better
much higher accuracy
so less amount of computation but higher
accuracy
since tsm is so small and light weighted
we can carry out efficient inference on
these edge platforms on adjacent nano
consuming only 4.5 watts it can achieve
74 frames per second at a energy
consumption
of only led bulb level
so paving the way for this energy
efficient ai
even on a raspberry pi it can achieve 14
frames per second
on the samsung note 8 mobile phone it
can achieve 29 frames per second
so here we have
the i3d comparison so compared with
conventional 3d convolution based method
which runs which requires 164
milliseconds to run each video now it's
only 17 milliseconds per video
and throughput wise we can improve the
throughput so here each row is a row of
videos
and we can improve the throughput from
6.1 videos per second to 77.4 videos per
second
with even better accuracy
so here we can recognize some
paths very accurately
for example moving something closer to
something
and hitting something with something
and we all we can also dissect the
semantics of each channel like moving
something away this is in frame number
three four and five is indicating we are
moving something away
similarly for wiping the spatial and
temporal frames
is annotated it can be
interpreted to see which frames and
which locations
are doing the action
so beyond efficient inference we also
scale up
the distributed training
so we use the
azamite supercomputer which has six
nvidia
v100 gpus connected by infiniband
and we can scale it up to 1536
gpus reducing the trading time from 49
hours and 15 minutes to only 14 minutes
so that's
from more than two days of training time
to only 14 minutes from just a cup of
coffee
so there's 211x speed up compared with
this theoretical speed up of 256 times
and the reason is due to the smart
design of the model which has smaller
model size therefore smaller amount of
gradient does need to does need to be
exchanged over the networking
and also reducing a reduced data
movement from io therefore is no longer
data movement bounded
so here tsm has fewer flops and better
throughput and utilization compared with
the baseline i3d method
and in the middle tsm is light weighted
in
io
saving the disk bandwidth which
is can be fully hidden
uh and fully hidden and overlapped with
the computation well the baseline method
still a big chunk of the prime is is
wasted on the
i o due to the slow disc
and on the right hand side tsm has a
better scalability uh without the number
of gpus the scalability is decreasing
much slower compared with the baseline
so the scalability is defined
as the actual speed up compared with the
theoretical speed up
so we can scale up dsm
for batch size up to 12 k without the
degradation of the error rate
and compared with the baseline i3d
method tsm can improve
the scalability from 1.6 times to 2.9
times due to the smarter model design
okay so having talked about scalable and
efficient vision applications let's
switch here to talk about tiny ml and
efficient natural language processing
we first review this slide we're
training a single a model using your
architecture search but this evolved
transformer is taking as much carbon as
five cars in their lifetimes
and how they'll save this search cost so
we can use this one small approach okay
so we can design a wise file transformer
just train only once but can be deployed
by many different scenarios
a smaller model for iot device a large
model for the gpu device
and measured on the raspberry pi it can
achieve
a 2.7 x latency reduction and three
times seven times 3.7 times reduction of
the model size from 175 megabytes to
only 48 megabytes
while the search cost can be reduced by
four orders of magnitude since the
training time is fully amortized
by different scenarios and also this is
a one-shot approach
so this
hardware aware transformer can also be
can be combined with conventional model
compression techniques to further boost
the compression ratio so all together we
can reduce the model size from 705
microbites to only 28 megabytes so
that's 25x
reduction of the model size while the
accuracy
the machine translation performance
measured in blue score
is well maintained from 41.2 to 41.1
so beyond this hardware aware
transformer we also investigated another
technique called spatin
which means sparse attention to improve
the efficiency of natural language
processing tasks
so basically the human language can be
inefficient as the height line of this
imagine use highlighting our work
if we shadow away human can and be just
keeping two two words out of five
language inefficient we can still
understand
the meaning of the whole sentence
but we can say with computation rather
than processing five tokens now we need
to process only two tokens
in the example on the left we can
perform such cascade token pruning on
this sentence as a visual trait the film
is almost perfect we can prove from
eleven tokens to five tokens as straight
feel more perfect
and we can further prove that only two
tokens feel more perfect and we can
still classify the sentiment to be
positive
so this cascade pruning it will
prune those unimportant tokens and has
on the fly and doesn't affect the
accuracy
this is fundamentally different from
weight pruning since there is no weight
in the attention mechanism
and the proof the token does need to
needs to be pruned has to be determined
dynamically
for example we can accumulate vertically
for the attention score for different
words and add that the visual game is a
lot more fun than the film
so the accumulated probably attention
probability is much lower for these
tokens such as i the
and the period
therefore we can remove those tokens
while keeping the performance
the second technique beyond this sparse
attention is the progressive
quantization
so the idea is we want to use as fewer
bits
as possible
and the youtube intuition is that the
larger the max attention probability the
smaller the attention error if we just
use fewer number of bits
for example in this sentence as a video
tweet the film is almost perfect
the attention probability is very equal
like a trade few more perfect are both
around
0.3 therefore if we use only 4-bit to
quantize the model it doesn't hurt
it hurts accuracy a lot due to there's
no
a token that stands out among others
on the bottom he is a very famous
researcher in computer architecture area
period
it is very apparent that a famous
is strictly dominates the other tokens
therefore if we replace that with four
bits there's very little degradation of
the accuracy
therefore we use four bit as much as
possible and only use high precision
when the max pro potential probability
is low and even
by combining them together
we built the hardware accelerator which
is a specialized hardware to support
this sparse attention token pruning and
progressive quantization
it can dynamically select those
important tokens with a high throughput
high parallelism top k engine
and can support the attention operation
with high efficiency over 150 x speed up
on the gpu we also propose a hardware
support for general sparse matrix matrix
multiplication called a spark
it can achieve
two orders of magnitude and speed up
over the gpu
so here is the breakdown of the speed up
so 22x comes from the specialized data
path 3.4 x with hook and head pruning
and another 2.8 times from progressive
quantization
that's all for my presentation thank you
for your attention